destination vacances destination la mer
direction l'archipel des glénan au large
de la bretagne 8 il est une multitude
d'îlots très fréquentée l'été
quasiment vide l'hiver car lille laudrin
jean-jacques le garrec flânerie les
petits matins de saint nicolas en été
des buts par le passage du sang beau
c'est le nom que les habitants ont donné
à la seule belle de la commune c'est
aussi ce qui leur sert de réveil
ils sont 5 5 à vivre ici toute l'année
où il est distinct grecque après
plusieurs jours passés sur l'île lorsque
les visiteurs viennent pour la journée
ils se font discrets et partant à pêche
on se retrouve tous ensemble
peut être qu'on appelait déjà janvier
non non pas du tout
c'est ça le sait très bien que j'en sors
tout droit d'une carte postale de
pêcheurs bretons il n'a connu que la mer
depuis l'âge de 16 ans il relève les
casiers un art même si aujourd'hui on
vit difficilement de la pêche
la relève est assurée par son fils jean
michel
les plus bas
c'est la fin les de la rue répète et
j'en ai dans les tribunes
je partirai
la jetée de saint nicolas en était
ressembla grands boulevards touristes et
plongeurs se croisent l'espace d'une
journée ils ont en commun
seul ou de l'exil chaque mardi lulu en
mai les amoureux de la nature explorer
l'île c'est quoi ce village a vraiment
font très rustique 1 et l on était
patent 10 784 par les normands quand
vient le soir lorsque les derniers
randonneurs ont regagné le continent il
reprend sa vie de famille et ils ne sont
pas plus d'une centaine à connaître en
été ces moments privilégiés à pouvoir
s'endormir le soir on sent liée aux
ligaments